he is the creative director of
Awesomeness for the imagination agency
and he is Martellus Bennett along with
his book hey AJ it's bedtime good to see
you sir
nice to see you is what do I need you're
fine right there okay never mind
I think your voice is curly Ricky Bobby
we need to know what to do at his hands
you're fine just just sit there all
right is it I have to turn to my I guess
my my creative director of Awesomeness
of sound he's fine perfect yeah you're
good
oh good how you doing I'm excellent yeah
life is good life is always good how's
the hobbies book come about here I know
that you've been interested in
children's books for quite some time and
this is your second book now so how did
you get into children's books in general
well I've always wanted to make content
so like as for me he's always like I
grew up watching Disney and you know
Nickelodeon and Cartoon Network and
always loved the people who told stories
for the majority you know there's one
thing about telling stories at home but
then where you could tell stories to
everyone in the world those are the best
those are the best ones so one of my
ultimate goals were to was to be able to
tell those stories to kids all over the
world and I like children's content
because to me it brings families
together
yes so like a kid can't just go see
Dominions by themselves right a family
asset you know mom dad or someone has to
take them so that's why I always love
children's content so like a bedtime
story like a parent has to read it to
the kid you don't just bleh here you go
you [ __ ] okay go good luck put
yourself to bed
so always love children's book cuz the
idea of like someone sitting down and
read it to the children that interaction
is an important one so that's why most
of the stuff I do is is in the
children's content space and the AJ is
your daughter AJ's based on my daughter
and there's mainly because when she was
born and you really don't think about
these things until you have your own kid
right when she was born no trying to get
children's books with characters that
look like her mm-hmm there's not very
many you know then you start looking at
it's like man there's this huge gap of
representation for children of color to
be able to have books where characters
that look like them there wasn't focus
on their color it's just just like
really cool kids of color going on
adventures you know so and then you
start
watching all the content that's on
television right whether it's like like
I was telling somebody yesterday like
you're frozen there's not one black kid
in frozen right arendelle is just white
topia then you watch all these shows so
I didn't think about going back to when
I was growing up I had the same
experience so I felt like everyone else
already had their chance to create the
content to do so so if they weren't
gonna do it then I might as well be the
one to do it how has it been received
more tell us I mean it's been pretty
cool like people love it is still like
building them because once you the thing
about children's characters is
familiarity is a big thing so it's like
the more that you make it more they get
to see them then the bigger it grows
because until then like AJ has to
compete with like Dora to explore you
know and doc mcstuffins so if you see AJ
on the Shelf you see dr. McStuffins and
with the children its way it is there's
so much the way it's marketed there's so
much of it that you always gonna choose
doc McStuffins before you get his new
character a chance and you can pre-order
it on Amazon right now because that it's
it's coming out next Tuesday right yes
so you can pre-order on all sorts of
ways online right now and you can always
get a AJ it's Saturday right now cuz
that was released in 2016 yeah and I'll
make interactive children book apps so
like the first app is free the hey AJ
Saturday app is free online I mean on
Apple storage stuff and then a new app
comes out on the 27 as well it's
fantastic
thank you so what are you hoping to
create with the imagination agency
Martellus me trying to be like the black
Walt Disney I would love like I'm
fascinated about theme parks I would
love to have a theme park that you could
go to like I love to have blockbuster
films films that your children that
their children now will want to show
their trojans in the in the future as
well so it's just like I want to be able
to create the stories that could take
people places that they could only go
through my mind right so I'm wondering
what you thought of Black Panther then I
mean that that had to be something when
you saw the popularity of that yeah yeah
that that's
kind of what you're playing in to you
right now that there's not a lot of
superhero characters on the screen large
or small for people of color to say well
that's that's me right there yeah I mean
that's this one of big things like a lot
of is because Hollywood doesn't think
it's gonna do well but the movie like
Black Panther doing well opens up so
many doors for other black creators and
black content as well the thing about
Black Panther is like when you're a kid
you can't really read that comic when
you're 5 6 7 8 years old it's like when
you 12 to 13 sure I just think 12 years
of not seeing yourself as a superhero is
way too long I think kids should be
introduced to the possibility of them
being superheroes from the moment
they're born right because it comes into
your mind and subconsciously you start
thinking that I too can be super but
until then you feel like you're the
sidekick because most of the black kids
are put into the sidekick role well I
caught a sidekick syndrome and so they
always take an old like it's always set
up where like a white kid could have a
black frame but black kid can't have a
white friend the way the media portrays
them into the way they play almost
movies and most content so Black Panther
is really good because you know it was
like it was like one black one white guy
in a movie I don't know if anyone has
seen the movie but there's more white
guys wheeler alert there's one white guy
yeah I thought Black Panther was good I
thought I thought I mean for what it was
thought that was a good movie mmm Martin
Freeman was was it was that he's the one
white guy okay very good
he said he ended up being I thought it
the one thing I didn't like if he did
see the movie was that the fight scene
towards the end have you seen it I have
not yet no I'm not gonna tell you there
okay Martellus how old are you how old
is AJ and she's four and she your only
kid no she's my only one got three small
children by wife and I we were we were
planning on going out last Friday but
then we just you know it's hardly
because you couldn't take the kids to
see that movie well they I my
nine-year-old and seven-year-old say
that a lot of their friends have seen it
they want to see it is it fine for a
nine and seven-year-old good know it
depends on
he ran out of Star Wars saying I'll see
it in 13 and when I'm 13 not the
original the the latest the latest one I
don't like what they're doing with the
new Star Wars movies you know just the
stories are just thank you you know no
you agree with him I totally agree it's
the Disneyfication of Star Wars it's not
great I don't think is a great Martellus
Bennett here on the Rich Eisen show let
me talk some football with you what's
your what's your plan right now is
you're sitting here right now I'm just
you know just living life and trying to
figure out what I want to do next is it
to continue to play is it to explore
other options what is it that I want to
do you know and I think it's like after
10 years you take a such a toll on your
body not only on your body but mentally
so it's just like wearing mine in their
mental capacity over overall is it
something I want to continue to do or
not want to do I'll I don't have to play
you know like but if I do it like I play
football cause it's fun and I like I
enjoy stiff-arming people or and jumping
over people and competing with my
friends and things like they're so right
now I'm just no just work I've been
working out preparing to play be ready
so you know what to get ready but I
don't know I'm going to or not could you
take that sort of veteran path of wait
till the summer maybe avoid a couple
days of training camps that you've
already been through all that yeah I
mean so many offenses in a NFL right so
I mean my office now is one of easier
things because you you know how to crack
the codes I play with seven different
offensive coordinators or something like
this so there's only so much you could
do so
it's west coast and then there's
everything else you see what they paid
Jimmy Graham up in Green Bay no I don't
watch TV you just kids TV I only watch
cartoons and I wanna do want to know
what they paid him up in Green Bay they
my money I don't care
thirty million bucks nice I'm glad he
got paid that helps you don't help me at
all raises the amount of the people
tight end market row I think yeah I'm
sort of like you know if somebody gets a
sells their house in your neighborhood
for a nice chunk of change
yeah I think it's always good me
when guys get paid I think everybody
should get paid I wish you've got 40
million you know right like I want
everybody get paid you said it's not
your money I mean yeah it's not going in
my pocket like I ain't gonna pay
anything for my family so I really don't
really care what guys I get paid hey so
Martellus spending here on the Rich
Eisen show we did notice cuz you know I
follow you on twitter did notice you
tweeting out once you did at you in New
England parted ways did you get grief
from people about your your you're no
longer being employed in New England
because we saw all the tweets of you
saying the people that you know hey
we're all human beings as athletes I
mean we noticed that no it was amazed
like other guys like what you anyone
says to me it has no fit like again I
can't go to the bank with someone else's
thoughts with me right okay this is what
they think of me you should do this like
yeah there's no like I have no moral
bank for other people's projections onto
me and my in myself as a person so but I
see other guys like our guys tweeting
and retweeting things and it's just like
it bothers me sometime because guys are
humans like guys get cut guys get traded
one of the worst things about trade like
you can trade it you have no say-so in
your where it's gonna happen to you they
could trade you they're just looking for
the highest bidder what's the best for
their team they don't care what's best
for you as a human being it's just
trying to put you where they could get
something in return for a body right so
I think a lot of times fans missed the
concept that these guys has families
right and they're gonna have to up and
move like most people don't want to deal
with change these guys have to fear
change every single day because no one's
safe you could be just signed a contract
like Alec oh good like Alex Ogletree did
big contract and dinner next year you
said you're getting a home in LA we're
moving here I've been a part of this
franchise and then next thing you know
you gotta up and move to New York and
then once you start having families
that's some hard to do guess it well no
and not twice okay it's okay it's okay
no it's okay please yeah it's absolutely
fine yeah I can't say it it's okay but
no no keep but you're you're absolutely
right you're absolutely right that
somebody sits here in Los Angeles and
then they have to now suddenly go to New
York right and
and then and then here's what I'd like
to do I'd like to take a break come back
spend one more segment with you here
because I want to talk about you know
obviously your brother going to
Philadelphia and the grief that Richard
Sherman has gotten it further once San
Francisco when when it was Seattle that
said we're done here
yeah you know I mean I I don't
understand it so I do want to continue
this conversation in a second here
especially since also our alma mater
czar going at it in the sweet 16
you don't know you really doesn't tell
me so you're sick I'm so glad because
again I've it you know I've really
enjoyed watching you play and how you
and your brother go about your business
so I'm glad you're here for that I'm
glad we're talking about your books and
I'm glad just to get you out yeah out on
the show so we could tell you what's
going on in the world might tell us I
know I appreciate I read books I read a
lot of bull hit that next is closing
like some yeah what they're not dogs
we'll get it there's gonna be a sale my
daughter's birthday was recently you
know I thought there's gonna be a sale
there was no sale there's no looking
everything they're liquidating
everything I was like let's go there to
go get her gifts and get 50% off to 75%
off they need to get rid of everything
take this take this we would everything
is full price I was like really got here
too early you know it's like you want to
go like you goes buy some people house
and I want to sell anything in the house
and didn't they die and everything's for
sales going on the business yeah I mean
Bennett dollars yeah it's hard it sells
like toys like if you think about toys I
know you gotta go thinking about Jacob
but you think about toys you got a build
a place of wonder right I think toys of
Russia's become became a department
store so it used to be fun to go in
there and sport and play with the toys
and things like that but now you have to
change your experience because now you
can just do it on Amazon right I'm had
to go there and now I can get the toy
tomorrow like the Amazon you order
something on Amazon and it's like ding
dong you might what I just ordered it 30
seconds ago
my daughter's right you know so I was
like so I think they just didn't curated
experience for kids to enjoy like you
know so just weird so we'll be back with
Marty Soros Rex as he's known on Twitter
at a moment with Scott Hamilton right
behind him again check out hey AJ it's
bedtime a new children's book from the
Creator director of awesomeness from the
imagination agency Martellus Bennett it
is available right now online you can
also get the children's app associated
with it online the same things already
available for a hey AJ it's Saturday a
book and app that was released just a
couple of years ago a couple more
minutes left with Martellus Bennett here
before Scott Hamilton joins us in studio
your brother is now in Philadelphia
there was a lot of I don't know because
you say you're you don't listen to TV or
watch it much a lot of talk about that
your brother was part of the release
with him and Sherman Sherman released
your brother traded because Seattle
didn't want guys who are speaking on
social issues as much anymore would you
agree with that assessment I think
that's a comes into a play woody I think
a lot of teams are afraid of guys who
have voices especially when they're
strong advocates but I just think is
really backwards you know if you had
these guys because a lot of times they
only look at me look at the masked
players but not as people and you think
about social injustice when we're done
playing before we started playing after
we're done playing we're still gonna be
black in America right I was black
before I start playing football like
been an athlete doesn't make me not
black I'm not Oh J you know Sam I black
comadre you know saying like Moritz no
that's not who we are so it's like these
are things that affect our lives like I
still get pulled over for driving while
black you don't saying cuz I'd be in the
bands I don't hit the windows you know
saying cuz I want them baby you know but
it's a real it's a real thing like if
there's like sometimes listen to a rap
song and there's sirens in a rap song
you get you start to panic and then when
you do get pulled over you you're afraid
of you're afraid for your life so if you
have a platform because we're not the
only people that feel like this right
everyone else in our community feels
like this so if you have a platform to
speak out on these things I think it's
your responsibility to do so and and for
teams they're okay with guys
not there and promote anything like you
know if you want to go promote you know
if you sell it condoms like they're
happy oh yeah if you selling a product
it's fine but if you're selling hope and
you sell in you know peace it's not the
things that we want you to prove we
don't want you to use our platform for
those those things you don't get to do
that here if you want to go sell Nikes
adidas stand on that platform and sell
wherever you want to sell but like if
you go out there and sell the idea that
there's injustice for people and a mass
majority or the your team or people who
have to deal with these situations I
just think it's just ridiculous for
teams to act like it's not a real thing
but in terms of your brother leaving
well Philadelphia's been a place that's
got its chock-full of socially conscious
players but so does Seattle - did you
think that that this played a role at
all I don't know I think it's I think
what happened in Seattle I think it was
one of those things where a lot of the
guys have been there they became bigger
didn't the Seahawks right because that's
the team that has the most superstars
out of any team in there like the last
ten years the whole you look at the
defense you turn around as early as Kim
is Richard Richard my brother Bobby
Wagner these are guys are massive face
they're all superstars like there's not
a lot of teams where you get that many
superstars in on one side of the ball
like that anymore so I think a lot of it
was like they had a lot of hangover and
those guys were you know they needed
change and I think the younger players
on the team looks up to those guys right
so they're not really worried about what
these guys are doing they worry about
the guys they're trying to groom to be
the next generation of players because
they all respect these guys and they are
the voice of the team so I think that
cultures and want their voice back so
you gotta get rid of those other voices
as well well thanks for bringing your
voice to this show come back anytime
please tell us you were welcome you're
absolutely anytime the imagination
agency the second book from Martellus
Bennett again hey AJ it's bedtime check
out hey AJ it's Saturday as well go
online and check out the apps as well
and at marty soros rex on twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience